d'abord avant de donner mon explication
de vote sur cet article 1er je voudrais
saluer l'évolution qui a été fait en
séance hier soir sur la question des
contrôles d'identité monsieur le
président dans la question préalable que
j'avais déposé ça faisait partie des
deux problèmes principaux à mes yeux de
ce texte d'avoir cette caisse est
faculté donnée à des dires récents au
sein de l'établissement de contrôler
l'identité de nos compatriotes en
parallèle du pass vaccinale le sénat
dans sa sagesse est revenu là dessus
merci monsieur le rapporteur et je
compte sur les sénatrices et sénateurs
qui représenteront la haute assemblée à
la commission mixte paritaire pour que
cet élément là soit absolument conserver
dans le texte final mais il reste le
pass fait le pass vaccinale et je n'ai
jamais voté depuis le début neil pas
sanitaire sous aucune forme de sous
aucune forme parce que je pense que
philosophiquement et politiquement il
pose des problèmes considérables mais
ils posent au delà de ces problèmes
politiques et philosophiques sur
lesquels je suis revenu hier un problème
concret c'est son utilité sanitaires le
pass sanitaire demain le pass vaccinale
ne limiteront en rien la contamination
d'un virus qui se propage entre vacciner
et je le redis je suis bien placé pour
vous en parler puisque d'en vacciner moi
même j'ai contracté ce cette maladie là
il ya quelques comment
non je n'en suis pas mort et je m'en
félicite d'ailleurs de me perdre dans
ces jeunes ne serait pas là enfin je
profite d'avoir la parole monsieur le
président pour alerter le rapporteur sur
le fait sur les sanctions pénales en cas
de mauvais usage de mauvais contrôles du
pass sanitaire demain vaccinale il nie
il n'y a pas ou très peu de sanctions
pénales quand le pass sanitaire est
utilisé à mauvais escient et au mauvais
endroit on combat et c'est normal les
faux-pas sanitaires on devrait combattre
la mauvaise utilisation du pass
sanitaire de macbeth vaccinale dans
notre pays les sanctions pénales prévues
dans la loi est très lourde
[Musique]